so you've been upgrading your setup
you've got a pretty sick
setup that you're streaming on twitch
with um i i got a note you got new
monitors
you got a sick mouse pad can you yeah we
just show it off a little
yeah so you're on a webcam so i'm gonna
like finagle this around
it's a little bit of a mess in here
because my dog has to start being crate
trained and i have a very small
place so i keep this crate in here i got
onesies
yellows and like blankets because we i
had to redo all the laundry
and i have no place to put everything
but and my cable management is atrocious
so
i'll take you here me too hi um
so here's you guys hey
this is my uh my newest tv from lg this
is
the lg c10 it is a 4k
tv uh hdr oled panel so you get the
blackest blacks
and it has um 120 hertz refresh rate
uh which is one of the first tvs i've
ever seen that does that 48 inches i
have it wall mounted with the leds
behind it
what's up mom i'm on the big screen
there you are
mama's on the big screen it also it's
g-sync compatible too so if you're team
green and you use an nvidia graphics
card you can
g-sync everything so that you have no
screen tearing i love that stream
uh that stream deck too yes so i got the
stream deck xl
from my friends at elgato um this thing
is six so this is connected to the
streaming pc which is over there so that
i can you know
switch between scenes super easily is
that a scarlet what's that
is that an m audio what's that interface
right so yeah so that's that's my
focusrite uh 4i4
i had the solo and i had the 2i2 first
but um
that thing is great i've got my xlr
plugged in which is plugged into my sm7b
which is on the
the rode psa1 as part of lg's um
like campaign for the tv they have this
zero in little
led yeah
it's super bright
it's really bright um i have my krk
rocket fives that are my
favorite studio monitors to use and on
top of those i have my elgato key lights
that i use for streaming
and one of the coolest parts about the
elgato stuff too is the lights i also
have the green screen
um and not only is it sick for streaming
but it's also really cool because i'm
doing a lot of like
zoom auditions and like zoom director
callbacks and things and so it's always
nice to have like a clean backdrop
and good lighting and so the elgato key
lights come in really clutch for that
yeah for sure i currently have an
awesome uh partnership with the guys at
steel series so i've got my apex tkl
keyboard
um which is rgb and has this sick uh
magnetic
wrist rest i love that that's so
cool this sick mouse pad from
steelseries um
which is super glidey and this is their
airox 3
wireless mouse which is currently
plugged in
um just to charge but oh it's got a
bunch of holes in it to cut down on
weight it's i think like 66 grams and
rgb very cool do you notice a difference
gaming with
uh the the lighter mouse i can do flick
shots
super easy because it's like i'm not
holding anything so like it's just
basically as fast as i can move my hand
which is pretty cool
wow that's awesome yeah so i've got um
another
lg monitor over here that is also 1440p
or 144 hertz and this one is connected
to
the gaming pc which is down here this is
from
my friends at nzxt um who
so we talked a little bit earlier about
how i booked 13 reasons why and then
like asked to buy overwatch um
one of the other things i did while i
was filming season one is i took
some of the money and i built my first
pc um
and when i was doing that i used a bunch
of components from nzxt
and then a year later they started their
build service
um at uh it's let's build.com
blv where they make like pre-made games
and i
they gifted me the very first builds
that they ever did
yeah and they're so cool too they have
great customer service
and whenever i had any issues at all
with my pc or had any ideas for upgrades
um their hq is in city of industry so
like just an hour drive from la
and so i would just bring the pc to them
they would do some cool stuff for
it and then send it back um so i've
since like upgraded the case to
uh one of their larger cases um and then
they were upgrading my motherboard
because they
developed their own motherboard for the
z390 chipset and so
my original processor didn't fit the new
chipset for the motherboard so they
got in their processor i think i have
an 8800k i can i can check though
here we go oh i love it yeah very
beautiful
and that's so what what a full circle
too i
exactly again like uh just like being
super grateful and coming to a point
where like
i got to buy everything and like say had
to save up to now being able to work
with these awesome companies
and that's also one of the like the
things that i'm very conscious about
when i promote or work with companies
is that i try to really only stick with
people that i've previously bought from
already and would recommend to anyone
um yeah so in this thing i have an i7
8700k
um 32 gigs of ram and then i recently
have gotten to work with the guys at
evga that make my favorite gpus because
they just have like the best build
quality the best coolers on them
um and so i recently swapped out my 1080
ti for a brand new
30 90.
[Music]
so so i have the 30 90 in there
it's amazing especially playing it 4k uh
on the oled um and then they also hooked
it up back here behind the other monitor
this is the xbox series x yeah and then
behind that
here is a tiny little small form factor
pc that the guys that dvga built for me
that has a 2070 super in it as my
streaming pc
whoa very nice you got that dual pc
setup
exactly streaming with ndis and
you know yeah software to like use one
mouse over everything
um wow very very
cool yeah um evga has their own capture
card that they released too called the
xr1 that i used to
game capture console gameplay and stream
that
um oh and then along with the steel
series stuff
steelseries makes this amazing wireless
headset
called the arctis pro wireless which
uses this little box
so i'm pretty sure that was actually
very cool yeah and so it's like super
customizable you can take the headband
off and these magnetic ear cups and that
works on like the ps4
the arctis 7x wireless for the xbox
series x nice dang i love that nice nice
yeah and so it's all like very pretty
very cool
so smooth oh it's like butter oh my gosh
and not to not to take not to take us
out of like the tech aspect of it but
i saw you have like a little xylophone
or or something sitting around can we
get a taste
i got a couple cool instruments so this
is actually my girlfriend just bought me
this and
it is um she bought this for me as a
christmas present
and was too eager to give it to me
because she wanted me to use it and
record it
so it's just here on let me put a little
taste
the more you know magical
that's
i feel like i'm either on a subway in
japan or i'm listening to like a morning
radio show
and either way i'm happy time for
devon's
life tips whoa
wait what is that i don't know what
they're called but i can play the harry
potter theme song on
oh yeah gotta hear it gotta hear it
[Music]
wait
yes i love it that is legit
wow that was great oh my god
oh thanks man thank you for taking us
through your setup wait what is this
what is this
is that you you're like oh yeah that's
me and my girl i keep her on the desk
all the time that way when i'm like
making music and stuff and then we've
got like
the guitars on the wall the bass guitar
the
acoustic sonic acoustic electric
helicaster
yeah telecaster my american ultra
uh or no that's a movie this is
that is what it's called um this is the
american ultra
electric and then over here we've got
the alessi
v49 i believe or no v61 it's the 61 key
midi controller
and zxt and zxt man reppin and then um
i've got my ukuleles on the wall here oh
i love that
and some midi controllers here we've got
the novation impulse 49 key
then the korg mini log hardware
synthesizer and then the ableton push
2 and then we also have the elgato
wavelength mic here that er though it's
just called the wave
and having that plugged in i use that as
a secondary mic sometimes i use my
sm7b as my main mic oh nice but having
the wave plugged in
allows me to use elgato's wavelink
program which is
a really amazing software mixer that
allows me to route all my pc audio to
different
like mixers so that i can adjust the
audio on the fly
if like if my chat says that like the
game is too loud for them i can adjust
the game sound for them
independently from myself which is super
sick
so very handy that's something i need in
my life i know also
so that's i'm gonna get that that's
incredible i love that and what do you
what daw did you say you're using for to
make money i use ableton
i use ableton live 10 um which live 11
is coming out so there's
there's ableton recording my audio right
now
you were going to show us something and
you're like don't let me forget or at
the at the end you were going to show up
oh
yeah for aaron it was the batman from
jim lee
oh yes yes all right so jim is awesome
by the way
he's like one of the coolest dudes um
and so he
gave me this hush and uh on the inside
he
wrote for devin stalking is a crime
because my character tyler is like kind
of a stalker in season one of our show
saying it and uh his signature and uh
dude that's so cool one of like the
coolest things that i have
uh comic book wise that is so cool and
just
amazing wearing my nzxt jumpsuit dude
you're really repping and i love it what
you need what you need is the
uh nzxt onesie i think that's what we
know that's what we need if they
sell one i would get it there we go nzxt
get on that
get our boy devon a hood yup
a onesie for with a hood um i love it
well dude
thank you so much again for taking us
through your setup i am of course
yeah i was taking notes and i'm going to
be uh
definitely emulating a lot of your setup
because it's amazing